todos tenemos historias que nos marcan
la vida yo tengo una en particular que
me pasó cuando tenía unos 19 años y
quise conocer de primera mano la
experiencia de fútbol por la paz que
trabajaba con jóvenes vinculados a
grupos armados en la comuna nororiental
de medellín
generan ese entonces la ciudad más
violenta del mundo vivíamos todos llenos
de miedo y de terror recuerdo
perfectamente que cuando llegue un joven
de mi edad me miró a los ojos me puso la
mano en mi hombro y me dijo tranquila
bonita que ese miedo que usted tiene de
venir acá lo sentimos nosotros de bajar
a su barrio
ese momento me marcó la vida supe que
quería dedicarme a conectar mundos
opuestos a contribuir de alguna manera a
la construcción de sociedades más justas
y más incluyentes y en este camino llevo
cerca de 20 años he tenido la
oportunidad de liderar y crear distintos
emprendimientos sociales y ambientales
entre ellos la fundación mi sangre que
hoy dirijo
cuando yo llegué a mi sangre hace unos
diez años la fundación se dedicaba a
brindar acompañamiento psicosocial a
víctimas de minas colombia se peleaba el
deshonroso puesto número 12 en el mundo
con más víctimas de minas
cuando llegue a la fundación lo primero
que hice fue empezar a conocer de cerca
los proyectos que tenían en marcha y
debo confesar que llegué con algunos
prejuicios y que mi nivel de escucha era
supremamente limitado yo simplemente re
confirmaba mis opiniones y mis juicios
veía las víctimas con muchísimo dolor y
lástima y las entendía casi que como
agentes pasivos
y poco a poco fui entendiendo la
importancia de la escucha para llegar a
un diálogo generativo y así lograr
soluciones más profundas el hombre en
cambios más estructurales uno de los
peores errores de la comunicación es que
escuchamos para responder y no para
aprender y mucho menos para co crear fue
así como me propuse a abrir la mente
abrir el corazón a empezar a dialogar
con ellos de una manera mucho más
profunda y poniéndome en sus zapatos
pude entender como muchas de estas
víctimas en particular jóvenes con
quiénes experimentábamos con arte y
lúdica para la sanación podían
trascender ese papel de víctimas para
convertirse en agentes de cambio para la
construcción de una cultura de paz y fue
así que redefinimos nuestro propósito
llevamos ya 10 años
activando ecosistemas y desarrollando
capacidades para prevenir riesgos y
violencias y para que las nuevas
generaciones
sean protagonistas en la construcción de
una cultura de paz
en mi camino como emprendedora he tenido
la posibilidad de conocer cientos de
iniciativas de cambio social y ambiental
del sector público del sector privado
del sector social algunos se refieren a
esto como el movimiento social más
grande de la historia y lo cierto es que
sí es muy emocionante ver que cada vez
más personas quieren trabajar por esto
pero también debemos reconocer que
muchas de estas iniciativas no están
logrando los cambios estructurales que
necesitamos lograr como sociedad
y esto en gran parte se debe a que
seguimos abordando los síntomas de los
problemas y no las raíces más profundas
de ellos
otro saber investigador y profesor del
mit y especialista en liderazgo y cambio
sistémico habla de tres raíces muy
profundas que son comunes a todos los
problemas que debemos detenernos para
entender y abordar de una manera mucho
más profunda el primero son las
estructuras o las dinámicas que crean
esos problemas sociales el segundo son
los paradigmas o esquemas mentales con
los que abordamos esa realidad y la
tercera raíz es el nivel de conciencia
desde donde operamos yo no voy a
detenerme a explicar sus teorías a
cabalidad quiero simplemente referirme a
estas tres raíces explicando los con mi
propia experiencia en prevención de
violencia y construcción de paz
el primero estructuras se refiere a
todas esas dinámicas que de una u otra
manera crean esa problemática entonces
pensando en temas de prevención de
violencia y construcción de una cultura
de paz
un síntoma son por ejemplo los
homicidios o los robos las riñas la
solución más obvia es tener más policías
o fortalecer las cárcel las que puede
ayudar de una u otra manera pero nunca
será suficiente porque no estamos
abordando las cláusulas las causas
estructurales de estos problemas sin
querer hacer un análisis profundo
nosotros hemos identificado por ejemplo
que la ausencia de ambientes protectores
en la familia en el colegio en grupos
juveniles como quiera llamarse es una de
las grandes causas de la violencia o la
ausencia de referentes positivos para
jóvenes que crecen en condiciones de
mucha vulnerabilidad o la ausencia de
educación pertinente y desarrollo de
habilidades socio emocionales como la
empatía
decisiones la resolución de conflictos
entre otras y hemos entonces empezado a
identificar todos esos actores que de
una u otra manera inciden en la
experiencia de las nuevas generaciones y
es así como a partir de la escucha
generativa y del diálogo con los
participantes a quienes servimos
hemos ido evolucionando y consolidando
un modelo de intervención con enfoque
sistémico que interviene en múltiples
niveles teniendo en cuenta todos estos
actores así por ejemplo trabajamos con
maestros en procesos de formación y
acompañamiento yo recuerdo mucho a
gabriela una profesora que estaba
desesperada con un salón de clase
insoportable en una zona de conflicto
donde había mucha agresividad hasta
amenazas por parte de un estudiante y
fue sorprendente ver como después de
unos meses de trabajo ella de manera muy
coloquial decía es que yo antes era
limón y ahora soy miel
y entendido que cuando un maestro se
transforma el aula se transforma y así
pasa con muchos otros factores que
inciden en la experiencia de los jóvenes
y van logrando que esas transformaciones
sean más sistémicas más profundas más
duraderas esto es solo parte de lo que
hacemos y no me quiero detener mucho en
eso pero fuera del contexto escolar
además de trabajar con padres con
rectores trabajamos despertando la
chispa del liderazgo como agentes de
cambio para la constructora para la
construcción de paz de cientos de
jóvenes en el país para que ellos mismos
diseñen las soluciones innovadoras a los
problemas de su comunidad relacionados
con temas de violencia y cuando ellos se
gradúan de estos programas tienen la
posibilidad de vincularse a la red
nacional de jóvenes constructores de paz
donde no solamente trabajan para dar
soluciones a nivel comunitario sino que
inciden a nivel de agenda y de política
pública y nosotros los conectamos con
mucho
otros actores como los medios de
comunicación la industria del
entretenimiento donantes empresas
privadas u otras fundaciones todos los
actores que de una u otra forma puedan
viabilizar la participación de las
nuevas generaciones como constructores
de paz en 10 años hemos llegado a más de
1.400.000 participantes en más de 120
departamentos
municipios
paradigmas es la segunda raíz que
debemos abordar y entender a profundidad
la historia de candelo que algunos de
ustedes pueden conocer sirve para
ejemplificar el cambio de paradigma que
tuvimos que vivir nosotros hace unos
años al interior
candelo es un pelirrojo hermoso de ojos
brillantes hijo de paramilitar el vengo
juró vengar la muerte de su padre y se
vinculó a un grupo hermano candelo se
vincule a la fundación cuando tiene como
16 años y unos de años más tarde nos
cuenta como el día en que él iba a
cometer su primer asesinato y tenía la
pistola en su mano sintió hip hop en el
fondo y pensó que si él mataba a esa
persona se estaría matando a sí mismo y
estaría matando los sueños que estaba
construyendo de nuestra mano
and the law es el fundador de una
escuela de hip hop en su barrio donde
protege hoy a decenas de niños de los
riesgos que corren en las calles y se ha
convertido en un referente no sólo de
ciudad sino a nivel internacional porque
fue elegido como global shaper por el
foro económico mundial
a nosotros nos exigió entender que el
mundo no está dividido entre buenos y
malos que a muchos de los que hemos
llamado victimarios muchas veces son
víctimas y por eso hemos aprendido a
construir sobre la capacidad y no sobre
la carencia y esto es muy importante
porque nuestros paradigmas nuestros
esquemas mentales crean realidades y los
vamos a ver solo como víctimas o
victimarios serán siempre víctimas y
victimarios pero si les damos la
oportunidad de experimentar su poder de
cambio serán por siempre constructores
de paz esto es un reto de todos los días
que nos exige como individuos salirnos
de nuestra zona de confort cuestionar
nuestros propios esquemas mentales para
mencionar otro ejemplo recientemente
decidí aceptar una invitación que me
hicieron a vincularme como miembro del
foro de responsabilidad social
corporativa de una compañía minera muy
grande si yo me aferro a mis paradigmas
están asociados a la protección
ambiental al derecho de las comunidades
más más vulnerables lo lógico sería
decir no pero si decidí atreverme a
entablar un diálogo profundo para poder
entender distintas perspectivas
distintos desafíos e incidir de alguna
manera desde adentro y aunque lejos de
decir que es una compañía perfecta doy
fe de acciones puntuales que están
tomando y cambios interiores que están
teniendo para mejorar su comportamiento
y su desempeño en sus actividades
mineras
la última raíz que tenemos que tener en
cuenta quizás es la que más ignoramos
porque parece por allá algo alejado del
mundo personal es el nivel de conciencia
desde donde operamos el éxito de las
intervenciones depende del estado
interior de quien las libera y esto
tiene una dimensión
individual y una dimensión colectiva a
nivel individual tiene que ver con lo
que ahora llaman mindfulness su atención
plena lo importante es entender que
nuestro cerebro tiene una parte que
compartimos con los animales y otra
parte propia de los seres humanos en el
cerebro reptil está el miedo la
inseguridad la desconfianza la envidia
la rabia la ira y desafortunadamente
desde ahí a pesar de que ya no
necesitamos habitar en esta parte del
cerebro
eran muchos de nuestros líderes pero lo
lindo es que podemos trascender y
existen técnicas muy sencillas para
acceder a la corteza frontal donde está
la imaginación donde podemos acceder a
mayores niveles de creatividad de
compasión de solidaridad de colaboración
así nos acercamos a nuestro máximo
potencial como seres humanos a nivel
colectivo tiene que ver el nivel de
conciencia con la posibilidad de vernos
como un todo y entender que el sistema
no es eso que vemos allá lejos y que
criticamos y atacamos el sistema somos
noto nosotros con todas nuestras
experiencias y nuestros puntos de vista
hace poco vivimos una experiencia
transformadora donde durante tres días
estuvimos con líderes de ex combatientes
de la guerrilla de las autodefensas y
también con militares enemigos acérrimos
que no podían mirarse a los ojos aunque
fue un trabajo
individual poco a poco se fue creando un
espacio de confianza de humanidad de
reconocimiento del otro y pudimos
entender todos que tu sufrimiento es mi
sufrimiento que yo soy porque nosotros
somos y con esto no quiero decir que el
nivel de conciencia se desarrolla en un
fin de semana requiere trabajo constante
y en nuestro nosotros en nuestro día a
día lo practicamos de distintas maneras
no solo a nivel de equipo sino con
nuestros participantes para concluir
quiero insistir en la importancia de
dejar de abordar solamente los síntomas
para atacar los problemas que tenemos
como sociedad tenemos que abordar las
raíces más profundas de los problemas si
queremos lograr los cambios
estructurales que necesitamos como
sociedad estas son las estructuras los
paradigmas o esquemas mentales y los
niveles de conciencia porque tenemos que
entender que los sistemas no cambian
misteriosamente de un día para otro
también solo cuando nos transformamos
como seres humanos y entendemos nuestra
relación con el todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]